[Music]
okay
okay pay attention to your kazushi patty
says
right here and it's going to eventually
his momentum is going to go like that
so uh when i go like this i don't want
to do this foster block again
and then i'm doing a muscle move so you
have to
keep his posture down keep it down
keep him in that uh lock outwards and
sushi power
so the dude that's standing straight up
here like that this is not going to be
shiho nagin okay maybe oh
crap okay
you have to know where you lose the
kazushi okay
so i keep the kazushi
keep the kazushi
and then a beginner mistake
in your work on the forearm you how you
grab too early
you grab too early and then
you don't have leverage here there's no
leverage
you have to get around the power of his
elbow even if he's tilted
there's no leverage here pull your elbow
down there's no leverage
you have to get around his elbow power
by coming to the wrist
when you get the wrist by not grabbing
early don't grab early
wait boom there's your
there's the wrist again
when you're doing technique you're like
can't get to the wrist
right you need to abandon the technique
[Music]
okay all right so i jack up
i can tell oh i'm on the forearm
abandoning the technique
come in and we'll do the arm triangle
buckle
boom
[Music]
um
he doesn't go all the way down i want
his
gravity to come into the armpit
if i leave my balance just take it all
the way down
[Music]
but ideally
okay